[Music]
os login is a compute engine service
that simplifies ssh access management
with os login compute engine iam roles
can be used to manage permissions for
accessing instances however having
multiple roles at different resource
levels can make it confusing to figure
out access issues let's take a look at
how to investigate ssh access issues
with os login and the iam policy
troubleshooter
first let's review a few different roles
that allow users to use os login
the compute.os admin login role allows
the user to ssh into the instance as an
administrator while compute.os login
allows them to ssh in as a regular user
the iam service account user role allows
a user to run operations as a service
account if an instance uses a service
account users will need to have an os
login role as well as the service
account user role
these roles can be granted at the
project level so that they apply to all
resources inside the project by default
they can also be granted at the more
granular levels such as directly on an
instance
let's walk through an example we'll
start by trying to ssh into my instance
one on the instances detail page we can
see the surface account for this
instance at the top of the page the ssh
button will let us connect to the
instance so let's go ahead and click it
looks like everything is working well
now let's try the same thing with my
instance dash 2. we'll head over to the
instance details page from the main menu
this instance is also running as the
same service account but when we scroll
up the ssh option is grayed out it looks
like we don't have permission to ssh in
but how can we figure out why the
instance is different
let's evaluate the permissions required
to ssh in in the policy troubleshooter
we can evaluate multiple permissions on
multiple resources at the same time so
that we can compare the results of each
let's check for the
compute.instances.os login permission on
myinstance1 and my instance dash 2. this
permission comes from the roles that we
mentioned earlier we'll add our user as
the principal and add the full resource
name and permissions for each instance
also since these instances are running
with a service account we need to check
for the
iam.serviceaccounts.act as permission
for our user
we'll use the full resource name for the
service account
the policy troubleshooter shows us
whether our user has these permissions
on the specified resources we can change
between the evaluations using the drop
down menu
the first view shows us that our user
has the os login permission on my
instance 1. we can also see the specific
iam policy details such as the user
having this permission thanks to the
instance level compute os login role
when we switch the view to the my
instance 2 evaluation we can see that
our user doesn't have the os login
permission on this instance since the
user doesn't have the right permissions
they can't connect through ssh
now let's switch the view to the service
account that we entered we can see that
our user has permission to act as the
service account and should be able to
use os login
these results confirm that our user has
not been granted the compute os login
role on my instance 2 but everything
else looks good
let's add our user by going to the
compute engine page from here we can
select the instance and grant our user
the compute os login role
after adding the role it can take a
little while for the permissions to
fully update you might need to wait a
few minutes before trying again let's
try connecting through the ssh again
looks like it worked and we can now ssh
in successfully
another option would have been to grant
the user the compute os login role at
the project level which would allow them
to use os login for all instances in the
project by default
keep in mind the security best practice
of least privilege and set your
permissions accordingly take a look at
the documentation to read more about
policy troubleshooter
you